dick trusted me but you never will
hey everybody its Charlie there's a
whole bunch of really cool stuff that
just happened so in the DC Universe the
flash people have been talking about
coffee shop girl Candice Patton has been
talking about Barry and iris having
children and then we also found out that
we might be getting a version of Jason
Todd on Titan's so if you're brand new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the DC videos it's gonna be
crazy stuff happening later this year
and there's a flash ring giveaway going
on right now all you have to do to enter
those just be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video I'll talk about the
coffee shop girls stuff first then I'll
talk about Red Hood Jason Todd on
Titan's so the big thing is that Candice
Patton and the producers have been doing
a bunch of interviews for the new
episode the interviewer asked her what's
the next big thing that you want to do
on the TV show and she point-blank no
joke answered bucket list item was to
see Barry and iris have a baby so we're
gonna need more diapers diapers
componentOne of new coffee shop girl
information so Candice Patton already
talking about having children on the TV
show this isn't a rumor this is coming
straight from her mouth then separately
the producers were asked what they think
of all the coffee shop girl theories
because there's been at least three
different solid theories in my mind like
one is that she's the daughter of Barry
and iris two is that it's their
granddaughter some people want her to be
tied to the Legion of super-heroes then
three a couple of other people want her
to be an alt version of the new
reverse-flash coming back to spy on team
flash but that's still pretty low on my
list I still think it's one of their
direct descendants because the producers
did say that people were about half
right so what I think that means is is
that she's definitely from the future
she is definitely related to Barry and
iris so daughter or granddaughter but
they'll probably change her name like
maybe that gibberish from the first
episode Nora isn't supposed to be here
also spoken within a couple minutes of
we're gonna need more diapers maybe what
the TV show did is that instead of doing
the tornado twins there's just one child
of Barry and iris
and they named it Nora after Barry's
mother so that'd be a big change from
the comics but they've done that before
in the past like that hole hunter
zolomon pretending to be Jay Garrick arc
that was never a comic book arc a lot of
you have also pointed out that coffee
shop girl acts a lot like Bart Allen
acts in the comics so it's also possible
that they incorporated aspects of that
character so it's very possible that she
has powers
she's a future version of the flash
because the tornado twins Bart Allen
pretty much every descendant of Barry
and iris has a version of Speed Force
abilities but just remember that of all
the theories that have been released the
producers said that everyone was only
half right so just assume the copy shop
girl is a combination of a bunch of
different comic book characters but
we'll get some more scenes with her real
soon so we'll have some more information
and we can adjust our theories
accordingly so no worries there bringing
it back around to Iris West getting
pregnant Candice Patton said she's
really excited to do that on the TV show
next season's crossover episode of the
flash will be its hundredth episode in
those types of anniversary episodes are
usually what you save really big things
for an iris giving birth to a future
speedster is probably one of the biggest
things the TV show could do so they
haven't confirmed any of that it's all
still speculation at this point just
keep that in the back of your mind next
season's crossover will be the show's
hundredth episode as you could probably
guess there's a new episode of the flash
tonight this is the rest of that clip
from the episode where they just tee up
the idea of using the new metas
abilities to steal Devoe's abilities and
if to vote against Matthews abilities he
could take away all our powers unless we
get him on our side first and he can
remove the meta DNA from the vote did
that work I mean yeah it could as best I
can tell Matthews abilities work by
melting down the highly concentrated
bonds between DNA that makes them
totally pliable so he can extract them
and infuse somebody else with the exact
same meta DNA melting highly
concentrated bonds melting point
write that down okay great so you guys
figure out how to get this mr. melting
point in the same room as DeVoe and not
get his brain sucked out I'm gonna go
get a couple of bear claws and go back
to my room it's not mr. melting point
look it's just it's just a melting point
you know somebody out there has
firepower's right now we need to find
them as much as we need to find Matthew
but moving in a Titans Red Hood
territory everybody was freaking out at
me on Twitter when they heard that Jason
Todd might be coming on to the TV show
so here's the deal everyone's reporting
this list of episode titles for Titans
I'll read it in a second but one of the
episodes is titled Jason Todd which is
why people are like oh they're
introducing characters in each of the
episodes like Hawk and Dove the Doom
Patrol if they're going to title an
episode Jason Todd it means they're
probably going to introduce the
character to the series
so episode one the pilot is called
Titans than episode two Hawk and Dove
episode three is titled Starfire episode
four is titled Rachel as in Raven
episode five as the Doom Patrol episode
six is the messenger episode seven is
supposedly titled Jason Todd so here's
the big thing remember the first time we
got a picture of Dick Grayson who's the
series lead he was in a Robin costume so
there's gonna be a flashback at the very
beginning of the series but daredevil TV
show style I'm not expecting him to take
the Nightwing name till later in the
series either the end of season 1 into
season 2 sometime in the future like
he'll go from being Robin - Nightwing
during the course of Titans
so if Dick Grayson has only recently
left Batman to go out on his own that
means that Jason Todd is a relatively
new version of the Robin character so
depending on where in the timeline
Titans season one picks up Jason Todd
could either still be a brand new
version of Robin or they could have
already gone through death in the family
he died and then came back as Red Hood
so because it's a TV series I don't know
if they're gonna go straight to Red Hood
right away they might let that develop
over the course of the series like at
some point they do a death in the family
arc he dies then at some point later in
the series he comes back as the villain
for a little while before becoming one
of their allies albeit a bit of a
standoffish Ally everybody knows at
least a version of the Red Hood story
like he always starts out as a villain
but then eventually starts working with
them but he usually only at arm's length
so think of the Titans version of the
character is being a little bit more
like Deathstroke like somebody who
starts out as a friend then something
really terrible happens he becomes a
villain for a little while then
eventually becomes more of an antihero
and there's this balance between him
helping and working against the team so
just let me know in the comments what do
you think about this the idea of them
doing red hood on Titans do you want
them to start out with that and then
just do Jason Todd stuff in flashbacks
or do you want them to do a full-blown
death in the family arc in the future
season because remember there's only 13
episodes total so there's not that much
time to devote to a whole bunch of
different characters but think about it
this way Titans is rolling all in
they're doing a version of Jason Todd
Dick Grayson Batman Nightwing the Doom
Patrol Classic Teen Titans stuff like
brother blood the cult of blood and
eventually Trigon so it seems like
there's almost nothing that's off-limits
for them but I think that just due to
the richness of the Teen Titans comics
they've just been really popular for a
long time meaning that there's that much
more story for them to pull from they're
supposed to be some new infinity war
footage so I'll try to do a video for
that if I haven't already so click here
for brand new flash and click here for
brand new infinity war thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight